- All right, hello everybody.
And thank you for all taking time
out of what's gotta be
an incredibly busy day
to join us for this webinar.
My name is Karen White, and
I am on the Product Team
here at Khan Academy.
I am also the mother of
two girls, ages 12 and 17,
both of whom have been out
of school since last Friday.
One with a distance learning plan
and one with no plan at all.
So we are definitely winging it here
in San Jose, California,
while we shelter in place.
I'm sure many of you are as well.
With me today, we have Dan
Tieu from our Marketing Team.
You can see him if you
go to the next slide,
see him pictured there with
his nieces and nephews.
And we have Sophie
Turnbull in that picture
with a helicopter.
She's going to be talking to those of you
with little ones about how to get started
on our Khan Kids app which is designed
as a mobile app for
kids two through seven.
I wanna thank our friends
at Bank of America
for generously supporting our ability
to bring school closures
resources to you at this time.
And finally, before we dive in,
I just wanna mention that
this session will be recorded
and it will be sent
out by email soon after
we finish this session.
Also uploaded to YouTube for easy access.
So if you need to step
away, if you miss parts,
don't worry about it, it
will be available to you
to review and to share with
your friends and family.
So with that, today,
we're going to help you
and your child get
started on Khan Academy.
If you are a teacher,
we're not gonna be going
through the teacher
experience in this webinar,
but we're gonna send these slides out,
and that link on the right over there
that says watch this webinar,
that will take you to
teacher webinar we recorded
earlier this week, it's
fantastic and it'll give you
everything you need to get started there.
We're also not going to
be doing a step by step
walkthrough of the setup,
but in a couple slides
you're gonna see our quick start guides
that actually will do
that for you quite well.
So, a little bit more about Khan Academy.
First of all, this came up
in a number of questions
from the pre-webinar survey.
Khan Academy is free.
We are a nonprofit organization
and all of our instruction
and practice is always free
to learners and parents
and their teachers.
Khan Academy is a trusted source.
You can trust us because
we've been doing this
for a long time, more than 10 years
with millions of users around the world.
All of our math courses
are Common Core aligned
and our other non-AP math courses
include both Common Core
material and additional content.
Our AP math courses are
aligned to the AP standards
and as I mentioned, we served, even before
the school closure
started, we were serving
well over 10 million learners
around the globe every month.
And finally, Khan Academy is flexible.
The Khan Academy main app
which is what I'm gonna be
talking to you about is
available on desktop, web,
iOS, or Android, anytime, anywhere,
translated into over 40 languages.
Sophie's gonna talk to you later
about the Khan Kids app
which is a mobile app only.
But Khan Academy is a main,
Khan Academy we're gonna be talking about
for the next 10 minutes or so,
is available on desktop as well.
So, now let's get into
what it really means
to learn on Khan Academy.
And in our pre-webinar survey,
the most common question we got,
and thanks everyone who took
the time to fill it out.
The most common question we got
was how do I figure out what
my child should be learning?
That's a great question
because if you're like me
you might not know exactly
what your kids were up to
right before the school closure started
and you're certainly not
used to teaching it, right?
I've been a mother to my
younger daughter for 12 years
and I've been her teacher
for about 12 hours.
So, I would say the first thing to do
is pat yourself on the back
for trying to pull this off
during a time that has
a lot of other stressors
in play as well.
So with that preamble, here are a few tips
to getting started.
First things first, look
at your child's homework
and their textbooks.
If you have access to a
parent or a student portal
for your school, you
might be able to log in
and see what assignments your teachers,
your child's teacher have
lined up before school let out.
That'll give you some
clues as to where to start
their learning path.
If you don't have that, that's okay.
You can select a course on Khan Academy
based on your child's age and grade.
And you can navigate your way through that
any number of ways.
You can start with
their very first lesson.
We're gonna talk in a few minutes
about how to start with
the Course Challenge
to identify learning gaps quickly.
Or you can let your child
choose where to start.
And even if your child chooses something
that kind of feels easy
to you, that's okay.
Those early math skills are foundational
to more advanced math,
and it's not necessarily
a bad thing to have your
child review that material
and gain confidence and really just keep
the brain training going
while we're in this
really unusual time.
Finally, for high school students
who are enrolled in AP or
are studying for the SATs,
we have most pop, the
most popular AP courses
on Khan Academy, and we also
have our Official SAT prep.
I can vouch for that as
a parent of a senior.
It is incredibly valuable.
My daughter used it as her sole way
to prepare for the SAT and
was really, really happy
with her results.
So, overall, if I had
to give you one mantra
to remember, it's this.
Some learning is better than no learning.
Don't let perfect be the enemy of good.
There's all sorts of things
that are being demand of you
right now and just get started,
it's very easy to course correct,
to change your learning
path and make adjustments
as you go with Khan Academy.
So, next up, I wanna share
those quick start guides
I was mentioning.
These links, again, this
will be provided to you
after the webinar.
There are three different guides here.
Two for Khan Academy and
one for Khan Academy Kids.
Just for a little bit of context
on why we have different guides
for younger and older
children on Khan Academy.
It basically comes down to the fact that
there are some regulatory requirements
around setting up
accounts for younger kids
that require your approval.
And so what we wanted to do was give you
the absolute fastest most
efficient way to get started
based on your child's situation,
and these guides are customized
for the fastest path through
to get your child learning
and then to get you
set up as a parent.
So, lots of support in
there in those guides.
What I'm gonna do now is
jump into what happens
once you're signed up.
And this is what you're gonna see first.
You're going to be offered the opportunity
to personalize your child's learning
by selecting their grade level
and seeing what courses we recommend.
Now, regardless of our suggestion,
your child can choose any
course on Khan Academy.
So if you have a child
who's really into math
and is generally performing
above grade level
and loves a challenge,
you can choose any course
that's right for that child.
Same the other way.
If you have someone who's struggling,
don't feel bound to the
grade level suggestions.
And after you've done that,
so you've selected a course,
you can select more than one,
you can always go back and add,
this is what your child's
experience is going to look like.
The courses will show up on the home page
whenever they log in.
And you'll see that
Khan Academy is designed
to give your child a lot of agency
in terms of where they're going to go
to do their next task.
And that can be great.
If you've got a child whose
engaged and motivated,
let them roam around, let
them take these things
in the order that sparks
their interest and energy.
It can also be a little
challenging and overwhelming
if you've got a younger child
to have so many choices.
So one of the things we like to do
when we're in the classroom
with young children
is say, follow the blue button.
You can see there that red arrow
is pointed at a blue start button.
That's pretty much always
gonna be a good call.
It will essentially
take the child linearly
through the course, starting
with the most basic skills
and advancing from there.
So, always an option if
you wanna give your child
a little bit more of a
sense of where to go next.
So, once you've done
that, if you were to click
into any one of those units,
those then turn into lessons
that include instruction,
practice, and assessments.
If you look at where those arrows are,
you can see the practice
exercise is on the right
and the instructional
resources on the left.
So, if your child is
practicing and is finding
that the material is a
little bit challenging,
but not so challenging
that they wanna move
to a different level.
They're likely to find
an article or a video
or a series of them right
next to that practice content
that can support them
as they're practicing
and reinforce those skills.
And then, the other
thing I wanted to mention
is this course challenge.
So every, most of our math courses
are gonna have this challenge,
and it's a great way to
accelerate the process
of getting your child
to that learning edge,
that place where they're
struggling a little bit
in a productive way, but not so much
that they get discouraged.
And the way to do this is
you scroll to the bottom
of the course page and
you'll see this button
that says, start course challenge.
These do take a little bit of time,
so you wanna leave 30 or 45 minutes
for the child to get through that,
but what you're gonna come out of it with
is the sense of the skills
that they're really comfortable with
and the skills where they
might need some more practice.
Especially given where we
are in the school year,
this is a pretty good option for you
because there's going
to be a lot of content
that feels familiar in most cases.
So starting at the beginning may not be
what you need to do.
The one caveat I'll say
is at least if you've got
a child who is generally
in the mode of performing,
being a high performer,
the course challenge
can feel a little bit like a test
that they didn't get to study for.
I know for my daughter when
I put this in front of her,
she was still in that mindset
of I have to get an A,
but really what the
course challenge is for
is identifying where
she needs to practice.
So I needed to really
kind of encourage her
and coax her along to make
her comfortable with the idea
that this wasn't a test,
she didn't need to get an A,
and this was really about finding
the best ways for her to
spend time on Khan Academy.
So, when they're practicing,
we've really designed
Khan Academy to be a
delightful learning experience.
We celebrate when they've leveled up,
they'll see confetti, there are
bells when you're on a roll,
you'll get a nice surprise every time
you answer a question right,
and there are videos and hints
to get in the moment support as you go.
We really try with Khan
Academy to celebrate grit
and perseverance, not just leveling up,
because that's what having a
growth mindset is all about.
So now, I'm gonna very briefly
talk about the parent tools
that you can access as part
of your parent account.
And the main thing you're going to do
when you're logged in as a parent
is look at your child's progress.
This report is essentially
like being in the room
with your child, looking
over their shoulder,
seeing what they're working on,
except without the looking
over their shoulder part.
So, it's almost like an audit trail
that shows you every
exercise, how much time
they've spent on it and how they did.
And there's really three values I think
that are going to be helpful to you
as you're coaching your child
or thinking about how
to motivate their work.
There are two numbers you'll see in there,
the two numbers, both say
three in this particular case.
One is the time spent on exercises
which is the real practice
of applying the skills,
and the other is the total
learning time on Khan Academy
which includes things like watching videos
or reading articles.
You're looking for in general
a mix of those things,
not just the instruction,
but also the practice.
And then, the third
thing you're going to see
are those little arrows, you
can see a little green one
there on the screen.
That's going to tell you when a skill
is leveling up or down.
And what we essentially mean by that
is your child is in, if
the skill is going up
it means they're making
progress towards mastery
of that skill.
If mastery sounds like a fancy term,
what it really means is
this child is getting
so good at this skill that they could
probably explain it to somebody else,
they could almost teach it.
There also are going to be red arrows
if the child is struggling
and maybe going down a level
on a skill, and those
are your opportunities
to say hey, let's lean
in a little bit here,
maybe review some videos and
support them with instruction.
So, this is all a good segway
into the last few minutes
I'm gonna spend on Khan Academy
before turning it over to Sophie.
And it's really about how do we motivate
and structure the student's day.
Let's face it, it's hard,
it's a lot competing
for your child's attention
right now, let alone your own,
and just be kind to yourselves.
But I always like to remind myself
that at the end of the
day, yes, I want my kids
to be learning, but the
most important thing
is we're all gonna be stuck
in this house a lot together,
so we have better get along.
So, in terms of setting goals,
it's great to include your
children in the process,
they're going to be more
invested if you do it that way,
and take it one day at a time.
If the goals you set for your first day
don't turn out to be
particularly realistic
given your situation, stay flexible,
let yourself, give yourself some slack,
we're all in uncharted
territory right now.
And then recognize milestones.
We always like to
celebrate both the progress
and the effort.
So when you look at those
numbers around time,
that's one of the ways you
can congratulate your child
for making the effort, and
then look for those level ups
as an indication that your
child is making progress.
All right, one last thing.
I think some of you probably have seen
we have posted online
a number of templates
for daily schedules that can help you
just get a little bit
more of that structure
that helps your child
be calm, creates a sense
of predictability, and gives
you some room to maneuver
because you have a sense of
how your day is going to go.
So feel free to click through on those
when you get the materials
and hope that they are helpful
to you as they have been to me
in terms of giving your
children some structure
and order in what is
kind of a chaotic time.
And with that, I will turn
it over to you Sophie.
- Hi everyone, I'm Sophie
from Khan Academy Kids.
And tonight, I'm really
excited to walk you
through the basics on getting set up,
how to learn at home with your
kids on Khan Academy Kids.
Khan Academy Kids is made by Khan Academy.
It's a mobile app that is
separate to the Khan Academy app
or the Khan Academy desktop experience
and it's designed especially for children
ages two through seven.
It's available on your mobile,
be it an Apple iOS or Android
as well as touch screen Chromebooks,
and you can find it in the
app store that you use.
So, what we're going to do right now
is quickly watch a demo
of how to get set up
on Khan Academy Kids
in about three minutes.
So the first thing you want to do
is go to your app store and
download Khan Academy Kids.
Once you've done that,
you can open our app
and you'll be greeted
by our fun characters.
- Khan Academy Kids.
- [Sophie] Cody, Ollo,
Sandy, Rhea, and Peck.
You'll be taken to a signup screen.
Click signup and enter your email.
We use this email to create your account
and we're going to ask you to verify it.
So once you've entered
it and clicked next,
you'll receive an email
in your email inbox
and you want to click the verify
email button in that email,
and then you are set
to go back into the app
and start creating accounts for your kids.
Click next here and here you are.
First, we're going to add the
name of our first child, Kim.
Kim is six and we'll select
an avatar for Kim, a dolphin.
Ready to start learning now,
but we'll quickly show you
how to create a profile for another child.
If you swipe up into the parents section
you'll see Kim's account
there, tap the new button,
swipe up, and enter the name
of the next child, Oscar.
Oscar is actually older, he's seven,
and he is going to be a tiger.
And now we have two children's
profiles, Kim and Oscar.
We're going to start learning
with Kim, so we tap Kim.
And if we press the play button here,
we'll be in our
personalized learning path.
It'll serve up age appropriate
activities for your child
like this one.
- And together they
have five toy dinosaurs.
- If you wanted to do self serve
you could click in the top left corner
on the library icon, then
you can scroll through
all of our activities, books, and videos,
our reading, our logic,
social emotional learning,
and you can pick out
what your child works on.
We've partnered with National Geographic
and Bellwether Media to
offer a range of characters
and stories and formats
to keep your child busy.
And there's always the
offline functionality,
that suitcase under the word library.
We can't wait for you to discover
everything there is to
do on Khan Academy Kids.
So now, you should be ready
to get started learning.
And I wanna run through
a few of the questions
that we've been getting from
parents learning at home
with their kids.
I mentioned the home screen.
If you press that big green
play button on the homepage,
you'll go into the
personalized learning path.
And if you press the
top left library icon,
you'll go into the library.
Well, what's the difference
between those two?
The personalized learning
path is an automatic playlist
of all of our activities,
math and reading,
social emotional learning,
books and videos,
and they get served up to your child
to meet them where they're at,
so they're age appropriate
and they're automatically served up.
The learning path might be a good idea
if you just can't be
there to pick and choose
every activity that your child is doing
for a certain part of the day.
The library is where is
where you can self serve
out of our catalog of activities.
It's the blue, the book icon
in the top left hand corner
of the home screen.
All of the activities are the same.
It's just about how
they're served up to you.
Do you want to pick and choose
what your child is doing
from one activity to the next
or are you happy to
let them work their way
through the personalized learning path?
That's totally up to you.
Now, I wanna cover some quick tips
for learning at home
with Khan Academy Kids.
All of Karen's points about
having a daily schedule,
but being flexible, and
motivating kids at home
being terribly difficult apply
to two to seven year olds.
On the technical side
though, I wanna point out
a couple of things.
If you have to go offline, I
mentioned the suitcase icon
in the library, tap that.
All your child's progress will be saved
and uploaded when you go online next.
If you want to view progress,
go into your child's
library view and you'll see green, yellow,
and red check marks indicating
whether they've mastered
something, they're still working on it,
or they're yet to work on it.
On the content side,
there are a few things
that parents have pointed out to us.
Parents are loving using
out the thousands of books
that we have to read to their children.
We have books on everything from animals
to feeling frustrated.
So, have at it in the book section.
Parents have also been
saying that they're enjoying
the healthy habits throughout the act.
There are activities on
things like saying hello
and making friends, even
getting dressed in the morning.
Some of these habits that are so important
when we're couped up inside.
And so, I encourage you to check
those out in the logic tab.
And then, finally, in the create tab,
your child can do something
creative like drawing,
making a card for a friend,
you can screenshot it
and send it on, and Khan
Academy Kids is really focused
on not just math and reading
the core academic subjects
for two to seven year
olds, but also making sure
kids are creative, that
they're interacting with you,
that they're moving around,
getting up and jumping
and making zoo animal noises
and really developing their whole selves.
The last thing I wanna mention
is that there is some places you can go
for more information.
So teachers should look
out for the Teacher Guide
that is linked in the quick start handout
that we are posting on this webinar.
It has a whole lot about
how you might teach remotely
with Khan Academy Kids.
And if you have any questions
about getting started,
please email khan, that's
K-H-A-N, kids@khanacademy.org.
And you should follow us on social media
if you're into that for daily activities,
things like circle time and
what to do with your kids
on Khan Academy Kids.
Thanks so much.
- All right, thank you Sophie and Karen.
Hi everyone, it's Dan here.
I'd like to for y'all to do two steps
before we open it up to live questions.
First, if you can all go
out to the handout section
and grab the cheat
sheet, it contains guides
for this entire process, from
finding the right content
for your kids, to tracking their progress,
and to creating structure and motivation.
It also contains step by step instructions
on how to set up an account and links
to other parent resources.
So feel free to download it and
share it with other parents,
friends and families.
And secondly, if you have any questions,
please add them to the question box.
I'll be facilitating
while Karen and Sophie
provide their expert answers.
So, let's go ahead and start
with some good questions
that are coming in, and thank
you everyone for submitting.
So we have a question, Karen, for you.
Should my child have separate
account for me as a parent?
- Yeah, that's a great question.
And absolutely, we would recommend
that you and your child
have separate accounts.
First of all, you have a
set of controls and settings
that are particular to the parent account,
but there's a second reason
that I wanna emphasize
which is that you actually may wanna do
some learning on Khan Academy yourself.
I have personally found
that seventh grade math
feels like it was a really,
really long time ago,
and so while your child is
learning in their own account
you can actually go in as a learner,
and this is in the quick start guide,
and practice yourself.
So you'll have your own learning path
if you have a separate account
from the one you set up for your child.
- Awesome, thank you Karen.
This next one I think it's most
appropriate for you Sophie.
Is Khan Academy Kids integrated
with the desktop Khan Academy,
and can I see their
progress from the kids app
on the desktop?
- So the short answer is no.
Khan Academy Kids is a mobile app
and the progress that your child makes
on the Khan Academy Kids mobile app
will not be present on the Khan
Academy desktop experience.
We've designed it so
that it's touch screen
and it's especially for
two to seven year olds.
And I think in the future, we look forward
to linking those two
experiences, but for now, no.
- Okay, great, thank you.
Here's a question that
either of you can answer,
perhaps Karen you tackle it first
and Sophie, you can go next on this one.
So we have a question
from Matteas Devereus,
apologies if I pronounced
the name incorrectly.
So the question is, how much
should we supervise our kids
while they learn?
- Yeah, great question.
I guess my first response
would be, how much can you?
I know at least for me, I
am working during the day
even though I'm here at home,
so my ability to supervise
is fairly limited, and
I imagine many of you
are in the same position.
And we have designed Khan Academy
so that most children can
progress independently.
I like to make myself
available to be nearby,
but if you're supervising
because you want to hold
your child accountable, that's
where that progress report
becomes really, really valuable.
Your child cannot practice on Khan Academy
without you seeing it and vice versa.
So, that report will be your
way of staying connected
with what your child is learning
even when you don't have the
ability to sit side by side.
Having said that, if
you do have the ability
and if your child welcomes it,
it's a great, it's a great chance
to really be part of
their learning journey.
- Yeah, I would just quickly echo that.
It's great for parents to be interacting
with Khan Academy Kids while
their child is using it,
particularly in the library mode.
But if you needed to step away for a time
and have your child learn independently,
the personalized learning
path is really taking care
of things while you have to do that,
and you'll be able to
see a comprehensive view
of their progress when you
go back into the library.
- Yeah.
And keep in mind, Khan Academy is used
in schools all over the place,
and that's a situation where one teacher
has a group of 30 kids.
So, it's definitely designed for kids
to be able to make independent progress
through a combination of
instruction and practice
paired together without
direct supervision.
- All right, so I think we have
time for one more question.
Karen, this one's from Heather.
Will there be an answer key
to help grade if I'm a parent
and not in a teacher account?
- Yeah, great question.
So, you will not get an answer key,
but you actually won't need to
grade your child's practice,
because they are getting
real-time feedback
with every question.
So, as the questions are answered,
they will immediately know
whether they got the question
right or wrong, they'll
have access to a hint,
and they'll have access in
many cases to a rationale
even if they do get it right.
So, there's really no
need for an answer key.
- All right.
So, thank you Karen and Sophie
for sharing your expertise
with our audience, and
thank you to our audience
for taking the time out of your
busy evening to be with us.
We know there's so much going on
and we really appreciate
you investing your time
into this session.
We know that we hit our limit in terms
of the number of people who
wanted to join the webinar,
so we apologize for that.
So for those of you who or may know folks
who were not able to get in,
this will be, this will be
record, this is recorded,
and we'll be posting live online
and available to everyone.
And so, rest assured that this information
will be available to you.
And secondly, we also have
quite a few other resources
available on our website
at khanacademy.org.
There's currently a blue
ribbon at the very top.
We're adding new resources every day
and making changes quite frequently,
so feel free to go there and click through
for more information.
Before we sign off, please
do us one more favor
and take the poll that
pops up at the very end
of this webinar and
let us know two things.
First, how could we make future
iterations of this session
even better for you all?
And secondly, what kind of sessions
would you like to see next?
So this was obviously a
relatively high level session
to get you all started,
but if you wanted us
to dive deeper into
things like motivation,
specific courses like math or science,
please let us know, we're
here to support you,
this is the first of future webinars
that we wanna create to
be able to support you
through this time.
So with that, from all
of us at Khan Academy,
thank you again for
joining us, and good night.